- So, John, how has the role
of the presidency changed
over the last several hundreds of years?
- It's changed dramatically.
First of all, when the founders created
the presidency, they left it kinda loose.
They weren't exactly very specific
about what a president would do.
And they realized that
the first president,
George Washington, and this
is why he was so important,
was a man of virtue and
that he in his behavior
would set the precedence for
the next president after him.
That means the job is basically
handed off by tradition
from president to
president but that also--
- And the reason why they
didn't know what a president
should do is that there
wasn't a notion of a,
there wasn't a precedent
for being a president.
- That's right, they knew
what they didn't want.
They didn't want two things,
they didn't want a king,
they'd just gotten rid of one of those.
They didn't want a king
and they also didn't
want somebody who's
whipped around by mob rule.
Those were the two things they were
trying to get between.
But, a president has a lot of room
to move in between the two of them,
and they thought we'll put it
in the hands of a virtuous American.
George Washington, a good
first virtuous American,
and that person, through
their virtue and character,
would stay in the right place.
Would not become a king and
would not give over to the mob,
but it also meant that it relied
on the character of the
person in the presidency.
And so, each president
in subsequent years,
has taken shape in the presidency both
by what was determined
by their predecessors,
but also by what they could do in the job.
And what's happened is,
a job that started out
very weak in the American system has now
become one where some people think of all
the entire of American
government as the president.
And that's not what the founders wanted.
- But how does that evolve?
'Cause obviously the constitution talks
about the powers of the president.
So, how does it change so much over time?
- What happened was, when they originally
created the presidency there was a debate,
and the debate was, we need
somebody who can move quickly.
We can't always be calling
them in to Congress
because, of course, when the America
was started they used
to take several months,
or sometimes it would take weeks
to get on a horse and get to Washington.
So, we need an executive
who can move quickly.
Well, what happened was, in various wars,
America needed to move quickly,
and they needed one person to act
on behalf of the entire Union.
Well, there's only one
person who can do that.
But, as people wanted
quick action they handed
over more power to the president.
Congress, which used to fight
with the president a lot,
during the Second World War
and then on into our present day,
has given up a lot of its
power to the president.
One of the key ones being
the power to make war.
Presidents can now go and make war.
Well, that's not the
original way it was arranged.
And they've done it
because there is a hunger
in the country for quick action,
but the problem and challenge of that is,
if you invest somebody in with power
to do things quickly in an emergency,
they hold on to that power
and they don't let it go,
and that means that they start
doing things when it's not an emergency,
that is then not vetted
by the American system.
And that system has both the judiciary
and the legislative which are meant
to hold back a president who's trying
to act too quickly and do too much.
- Let's go on this notion
of making war as an example.
There's clear powers that Congress has
to approve a war, has
the power of the purse,
So, how did this happen?
They just do that as a ritual now?
- Well, basically there are times
and Congress tries and makes attempts
to try to pull power
back from the president.
The only times they've been successful
after the Second World War
is really after Watergate.
The view was that the president
had gotten too powerful.
That President Nixon, who left the office,
had abused the office
and so Congress tried
to pull some power back, but again,
political parties which are now
very close to the president.
It used to be that political
parties were not so powerful.
If I'm a Republican in Congress
and I want my Republican
president to do well,
I'm gonna give him the power he wants
because we're connected.
In the old days, if the
president in the office
was my party, well that's nice,
but I've got my own views
and I'm in Congress,
and I'm gonna do what I want.
And so, essentially a lot of these powers
that have gone to the president
have been handed over to
him, not with a ceremony,
but just by a lack of a
fight by members of Congress,
in withdrawing from their traditional role
as the founders wanted it as the key actor
in American government.
That's no longer case, in America today,
the president is the key actor.
- And then every time that happens
the next president or the
next several presidents,
we allowed that to happen to that person.
I should have that power as well.
- That's exactly right.
It's almost like the powers conveyed
to the new president like the
furniture in the Oval Office.
And so, they think, well this
chair's pretty comfortable.
(Sal laughs)
I'm not gonna get rid of that and sit
in the old uncomfortable wooden chair.
I want all the plush trappings.
And here's another reason.
American politics has created a situation,
and television has made
this so much worse,
where people run for office promising
the sun, the moon, and the stars.
So, they say I can, Donald Trump,
when he was running
said I alone can fix it.
That is not the way the
country was originally founded.
That one person could fix or unfix things.
It was supposed to be a country
with representatives
of the entire country.
But, politics has created a system
where, whether it's a
Republican or Democrat,
they run by saying I can do anything.
Well, that means when
you get in the office
you want those quick powers that allow
you to keep those campaign promises,
and those quick powers are only quick
if Congress and the
courts aren't in the way.
So, politics and the way you run
for office makes presidents want
to have every possible
power at their disposal.